mesdames et messieurs bon dimanche
est-ce que Justin Trudeau a eu raison
d'invoquer la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence pour mettre fin au mouvement
protestation des camionneurs l'hiver
dernier on s'est longtemps posé la
question le commissaire Paul rouleau
jusque oui mais selon lui pareil
occupation aurait pu être évité il fait
état d'une série d'échecs en matière
d'ordre public qui ont contribué à
rendre la situation incontrôlable il
n'écorche pas que les corps policiers
ils croient que les gouvernements
auraient dû mieux collaborer et mettre
de côté les considérations politiques
l'état devait de vrai normalement être
en mesure de réagir aux situations
d'urgence sans avoir recours à des
pouvoirs exceptionnels la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence n'est pas un outil
dont on peut se servir lorsqu'il s'avère
utile il s'agit plutôt d'un outil de
dernier recours
bonjour bonjour monsieur Mendicino le
juge rouleau dit que votre gouvernement
a eu raison d'invoquer la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence mais il parle quand
même d'un échec du fédéralisme à quel
point votre gouvernement doit porter une
part de responsabilité dans cet échec là
de ne pas avoir réussi à vraiment bien
collaborer continuellement avec les
autres ordres de gouvernement d'abord je
veux remercier le juge ou lot pour son
bon travail vous avez des raisons le
jugeur confirmé que le gouvernement a
des raisons était justifiées dans la
décision d'un invocation de la loi de
mesure d'urgence les raisons est parce
que c'était un situation qui était sans
précédent sur le terrain avec beaucoup
de perturbations à des travailleurs à
des familles à des communautés par tout
au Canada
et dans cette contexte là nous avons en
tant que gouvernement fédéral de voir de
gérer et on a pris la responsabilité de
d'invocation de loi de mers ou d'urgence
au même temps oui il faut prendre
quelques leçons et un de la leçon et
comment on peut mieux collaborer entre
les niveaux de gouvernement entre les
gouvernements et les services policières
et maintenant ont il faut étudier avec
beaucoup d'attention les recommandations
de le jour où donc il y a la
collaboration entre les gouvernements
une autre recommandation porte sur la
communication entre les corps policiers
parce que les corps policiers les
services de maintien de l'ordre sont
quand même passablement écorché dans ce
rapport-là et le juge recommande d'avoir
un seul responsable
coordonnateur national du renseignement
dans les événements majeurs est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord
le jugera déposé quelques
recommandations qui touchaient sur les
compétences les services policières sur
les compétences de la Communauté
intelligence il a recommandé la création
d'un coordinateur a pour l'intervention
et l'intelligence pardon et ça c'est
exactement
qu'on doit faire étudier les
recommandations parce que la nature de
cette manifestation était différent
était à unique était sans précédent dans
la vie de le gouvernement et un délai
les exemples de le travail qu'il doit
continuer avec et sur les outils qui
sont en force maintenant en rigueur
maintenant et oui de demander la
question si nous devons créer des
nouveaux outils donc
ça c'est exactement que nous sommes en
train de faire maintenant donc vous me
dites pas si oui ou non vous seriez
d'accord avec la un seul grand
coordonnateur mais s'il y en avait eu
lors de la crise du convoi l'année
passée qu'est-ce que ça a changé à votre
avis mais il faut premièrement comment
c'est avec les relations avec les lignes
de communication entre des gouvernements
il faut rester en contact toujours et
dans le contexte d'une crise nationale
oui il y a des défis donc d'abord il
faut il faut assurer que la ligne de
communication est fort deuxièmement il
faut oui coordonner sur l'intelligence
couronnée dans le contexte le partager
d'informations donc il y a des
protocoles protocoles qui sont en place
maintenant mais on va explorer s'il y a
des autres façons qu'on peut renforcer
le cours des nations d'intelligence
parce que les menaces
évoluer pendant les dernières années il
faut moderniser les outils les autorités
les protocoles ça c'est les le travail
qu'on va continuer et les renseignements
se trouvent entre autres dans les médias
sociaux et le juge rouleau disait
faudrait avoir peut-être un ministère
qui est responsable de surveiller ce qui
se passe dans les médias sociaux est-ce
que du rattrapage à faire de ce côté-là
en tant que ministre de sécurité
publique un de les choses que je suis
très préoccupé avec et sur la question
le problème de désinformation et à
l'heure actuelle il y a plein de
dissiminations pas seulement dans le
contexte de cette
crise nationale mais toujours sur
l'Internet sur la cyberespace donc
ça c'est un de leur recommandation qui
est le plus important dans mon avis
parce que il faut donner tous les outils
à les Canadiens de la canadiennes que
que il peut relier sur l'information qui
est correcte et pas sous le dessin
information monsieur vous en avez déjà
plein votre assiette vous avez le projet
de loi sur le contrôle des armes à feu
sur votre table de travail quand vous
avez vu le rapport rouleau les centaines
de pages est-ce que vous avez cherché si
votre nom était dedans pour voir comment
vous actions ont été évaluées par la
peur du juge rouleau est-ce que vous
étiez soulagé personnellement quand vous
avez vu les conclusions le plus
important chose pour moi et que j'avais
aimé collègues à participer dans le
commission la commission publique qui
était gérée par le juge ou non c'est un
exercice de transparence c'est une
opportunité pour expliquer à tous les
cannes à les canadienne qu'est-ce que
c'est le circonstances qui a contribué à
la décision de l'invocation et
maintenant avec le rapport final
tout le monde pour à l'opportunité pour
lire cette rapport pour éduquer et pour
comprendre comment le gouvernement fait
le travail essentiel pour les protection
de tout le monde pour le protection de
sécurité et le santé de Canadiens c'est
pas un job facile mais c'est nécessaire
c'est essentiel donc c'était un travail
important de la part de du juge rouleau
j'aimerais vous parler d'un autre sujet
important aussi celui du chemin Roxane
vous aviez dit que une entente était
apportée de main le Premier ministre
était moins optimiste que vous
finalement on en est où dans les
négociations avec les États-Unis pour
revoir l'entendre sur les tiers pays sûr
et si c'est pas bientôt qu'est-ce qui
bloque
d'abord il faut reconnaître que oui il y
a des défis sur le terrain à la cheminée
que nous sommes toujours en étroite
collaboration avec le gouvernement de
Monsieur LEGO avec des des fonds de
fédérales avec des ressorts avec un
collaboration ou nous partageons
d'informations c'est pas facile mais
avec une entente entre Canada et Québec
on peut renforcer le système en plus
nous avons un très bon collaboration
avec les États-Unis et nous restons dans
le processus de finaliser le
modélisation de cette entente ou encore
qu'est-ce qui bloque parce que finaliser
on a une on négocie c'est des termes
qu'on entend depuis des mois déjà
monsieur mandychino oui et moi et le
Premier ministre la ministre des
migration tout le monde sont toujours
avec un focasse sur sa priorité
oui il y a je pense qu'il y a raison
d'être optimiste qu'on peut conclure
cette processus mais il faut
parce que c'est un ensemble qui doit
marcher pour la bannière pas seulement
pour un moment d'entendre mais pour
l'avenir et il faut à mettre tous les
outils dans cette entente que donc nous
pouvons protéger le système l'intégrité
de notre système d'asile et c'est
important c'est important pour les
demandes d'asile c'est important pour
les réfugiés parce que ils sont un des
plus vulnérables groupes de personnes
dans le monde donc oui je comprends
qu'il y a beaucoup d'attention sur ces
dossiers mais on doit prendre le temps
qui est nécessaire pour arriver pour
avec une entente qui marche pour Canada
et les États-Unis on va vous redonner
rendez-vous monsieur Mendicino pour
avoir des réponses plus précises sur le
chemin Roxane je vous remercie beaucoup
à la prochaine au revoir